find your center of balance bro ready
hey guys
you asked me who i made on overwatch i'm
not going to get
not going to tell you i'm going to make
you wait for the footage that i have all
day
i'm fine you won't get rid of me that
easily
now you guys know my username as you can
tell i am currently platt
which is upsetting to me okay aggressive
i like it ryan i like it i'm not even
against it i'm not even mad at that
i'm healing you up keep swinging like a
champ baby diva you're low health
diva you're low health diva you're low
health wait winston wait wait wait i
gotta heal you up buddy let's go
let's go let's go easy work baby
i gotta pick two picks
what who's doing this the real one or
i'm the real doctor mike brother long
time no see black dog did you learn left
from right
you were messing with our minds i get it
no they're mines right
they can't hear our chat bro this isn't
call of duty where is this widow
she's on the left i got her i got her
good call out
all right soldiers down
widow's down
zen's down roadhog is the only one use
him for old charge
and keep pushing point get three on
point get three on point all day
all day every day you gotta love
overwatch i mean it's frustrating when
you have a team member that won't swap
you're begging them to go healer or tank
or shield tank whatever it is
but if you get a team that's in sync
even if you lose i think it's still fun
to play just because there's so much
teamwork
deciding what olds go first
i saved you i saved you black dog thanks
but uh
yeah oh yeah let's go
ah sorry mercy wait who sniped me
grind down
roadhog down
that's right baby guys i'm literally
fighting by myself here
what
[Music]
oh great first pick that's huge the
thing about overwatch is that
it's simple yet incredibly complex it
almost reminds me of chess
even though i'm not a big chess player
but this season i've been playing
junkrat a lot which i know may surprise
you in real life i'm constantly healing
people so i come home
i want to do some damage that's what i
do baby boo
that's what i do go left go left go left
or not wow okay my mic was muted this
whole time i'm a noob
yo reaper we really need you to pick it
up baby come on
our reaper went off second tank and now
has been just playing trash bag
i tried i tried so hard all right
that was a tough loss that's the thing
about this game like
i got up to 3100 i know it's not amazing
but
and then like in two days i dropped like
300 sorry that's
so this game is stressful that's what i
said on surgeon simulator this is the
most frustrating thing i've ever played
and i play overwatch but it's that good
kind of stress that when you overcome it
you feel good
mr pancake yeah mr pancake didn't i just
play with you
no okay guess we're not on talking terms
i'm gonna break everything in this room
why is is that recycling from the future
oopsy daisy double kill i'm gonna set up
up top here
and pressure them oh how did this zen
get up here i have a long run guys i'm
gonna be there in a few minutes
oh i got slept soldier up top he's he's
putting a lot of damage
good job genji
that's what we do baby that's what we do
keep it simple kis
someone called me but they obviously
didn't i was playing overwatch
easy pickings easy pickings boys
how did he snipe me that was really
embarrassing i hate playing against
decent widows
oh that's so frustrating let's do a pro
switch right now
that's what i'm talking about pro switch
oh my god what a noob that i am i didn't
see her from above me
gaming isn't my strong suit but reacting
to popular medical tv shows now that's
my thing
so click here for a full playlist stay
happy and healthy
but click the playlist